après de longues années passé à
travailler dans les hôpitaux en
métropole Marie espéy Gardiol est
revenue dans son île pour s'installer
comme exploitante agricole ce sont
terrain dans les haut de sain- rose elle
s'est spécialisée dans la culture de la
banane de l'éi et de la canne une
vocation tardive mais particulièrement
courageuse et enrichissante pour cette
femme au caractère bien
trempé le terrain il était déjà
disponible vous a fallu acquérir un
terrain ah c'estàdire le terrain j'avais
enfin le terrain terrain il fallait
acquérir le terrain mais le ce terrain
c'est un terrain Saffire quand j'ai pris
il était en friche on pouvait pas bouger
on pouvait pas mettre un pied c'était il
y avait des trous de partout il fallait
passer le but il fallait passer la
machine il fallait avoir beaucoup de
courage pour débuter beaucoup il y avait
pas de chemin fallait faire des des
sentiers partout au début c'était très
dur ensuite je n'ai pas eu de chance non
plus quand je me suis installé j'ai eu
trois cyclones un derrière l'autre donc
absolument ma bananerie à chaque fois
c'était par terre mais il fallait
reprendre le courage et reparre de
l'avant ce que j'ai fait aujourd'hui je
suis fier de moi alors pour avoir de la
banane de qualité est-ce qu'il y a une
manière de procéder euh oui il y a il y
a une manière de procéder voilà je ferai
devant vous les les gestes tout d'abord
je vais casser le baba enlever tout ça
de manière que les trips ne restent pas
dedans ensuite je vais la à la la
dernière main qui se trouve en dessous
je vais je vais enlever tout ça je vais
laisser que deux que deux avec ces deux
là l'énergie de la banane elle viendra
jusqu'en bas en arrivant en bas elle
elle trouvera ces deux ces deux bananes
qui restent elle va remonter dans le
régime et cela fait que mes bananes son
beaucoup plus grosses et beaucoup plus
jolies ensuite pour avoir une banane de
qualité il faut d'abord épistiguer tout
ça il faut enlever les lespistilles tout
ça dessus est-ce que vous avez appris à
le faire j'étais en Guadeloupe c'est
là-bas que j'ai appris à faire ça et
j'ai été suivie par un technicien de la
chambre d'agricultureord il y a à peu
près 6 ans de ça maintenant hein ouais
et je continue tous les jours à faire
les mêmes
gestes c'est un produit à base de quoi
exactement à base de karaté et ça sert à
quoi ça sert à à tuer les trips parce
que les trips si on on tue pas les trips
ça reste il y a les trips à pe des œufs
et ça fait des T Tach noir sur la banane
la banane ensuite je sais pas si vous
avez remarqué au marché il y a la banane
qui ont des taches oui des petites
taches noires ça vient des tripes des
œufs des trips et les trips sont des
insectes les trips c'est on fait en cré
appelle ça bébêes oreilles d'accord
voilà ce sachet c'est fait pour protégé
justement parce que là vous voyez s'il y
a un trips qui est dessus
automatiquement il sera tué d'accord en
mettant le sachet il est protégé oui
donc ça veut dire les TR je pense pas
les TR norement ne viennent plus de
régime là d'accord ça va être protégé
ena belle banane mais le produit n'entre
pas dans le fruit ah non pas du tout
c'est du Katé c'est un délai je crois de
de de ou 3 jours hein c'est pas un
produit quand même trop méchant hein si
vous avez pas de gant vous prenez la
banane automatiquement vous avez un on
qui va rentrer dans la banane ça fera
une marque aussitôt que la banane sera
mieux vous verrez il y a des marques la
banane sera pas belle les traces restent
les traces restent donc à la coupe de la
banane on met des gants jusqu'à la fin
d'accord c'est obligé hein oui voz
regarde il peut voir la banane
elle est jolie il y a pas de tâche il y
a rien il y a qu'une aucune tâche d'ici
peut-être de semaines elle sera bonne à
vendre d'accord dans 2 semaines et
pourquoi avoir choisi cint rose
justement pour cette plantation de
banane sain rose tout Mani la banane
elle pousse plus à sain rose qu'ailleurs
hein parce que la banane il faut
beaucoup d'eau voilà saint rose c'est la
capitale de la banane j'aime bien faire
la banane mais la banane c'est pas une
valeur une valeur sûre parce que si un
cyclone on a plus rien d'accord ouais
voilà c'est pour ça à côté de la banane
je fais de la canne à sucre
ouais il faut toujours être zaguer comme
là tu vois là j'ai ouvert ma vite là je
regarde si ça passe bien s'il y a pas de
problème est-ce qu'il faut une bonne
constitution physique pour conduire un
tracteur ou bien on peut conduire comme
une voiture le tracteur non pas du tout
pas du tout parce qu'au début quand je
me suis a acheter le le tracteur moi je
je suis je suis petite et je me disais
jamais je pourrais conduire mon tracteur
et puis je me suis dit une exportante
agricole elle doit savoir avant qu'elle
donne le tracteur à quelqu'un pour
conduire elle doit savoir conduire
elle-même alors j'ai pris quelqu'un qui
connaissait emmener un tracteur j'ai
pris mon courch de main au début c'était
difficile pendant un un mois ou de mois
je l'ai bien écouté et j'ai appris à
conduire mon tracteur
euh je prends mon tracteur pour mettre
le désirban et pendant la campagne sucr
mon fils ti les cannes avec il faut
combien de fois peu près par an mais la
canne on dab une fois par
an la CAN normalement après la coupe de
canne on met l' on attend peu près 2
mois et on commence à mettre le déserb
derrière vousz un grand champ de combien
d'Ar je dois faire à peu près j'ai 6 he
et dem en canne et voilà la coupe c'est
prévue pour le mois de juillet
normalement comme ça carrément met le
pied dessus comme ça là hop et ce n'est
pas difficile du tout hein c'est toutes
les femmes peuvent le faire si elles
veulent he et vous qu'est-ce qui vous
motive justement à avoir ce champ de
canne mais la canne à su pour moi c'est
un comment dire la canne à suc pour moi
déjà c'est je suis sûre qu' fa l'année
j'ai salaire c'est tout ça la banane
c'est différent les c'est différent tout
est différent les canes résistent cyone
r
cyclone c'est un pied qui me donnit au
moins
un ball un ball le vent a pris arraché
je remets un pied à côté d'accord je
repente à côté automatiquement ch FO à
chaque fois faut replanter mais surtout
dans dans une plantation de ce qu'il
faut faire fa mettre beaucoup d'arbr ou
des par exle a un pied d'avocat Maron
qui P vous laissez pousser ça protège
faut mettre des logag peu partout des
palmis un peu tout et ensuite c'est vous
à mesure que comment dire à mesure que
plus grandit vous même vous voyez s'il
faut enlever le Brison ou pas voyez si
faut le pied de palmier le pied de
avocat Maron le pied de l'ogan il faut
voir parce que le vent il vient il prend
le pied par avec aussi sur P il faut
tailler si vous taillez pas ça fait une
boule donc là on enlève les feuilles de
manière qu'on dégage bien le pied pour
bien voir les broches qu'on doit couper
hein voilà mais ça il faut le fait d'une
façon régulière non c'est une fois par
an une fois par an
voilà je veux dire après la la cuillette
la cuillette fait ça normalement hein et
à chaque pied on le fait c'est pour
fortifier le pied pour fortifier le pied
et pour que le cyclone quand si a un
cyclone le cyclone passe à travers ah
travers du pied
d'accordou et ça c'est plus le travail
du fils oui plus le travail de mon
garçon hein que que le mien il a une
formation aussi oui il a eu son son BTA
il a une formation agricole he et BTA et
ben tu la gestion et puis voilà vous
avez combien d'enfants j'ai trois
enfants deux garçons et une fille et
tous les trois ils s'intéressent à ce
que vous faites euh oui j'ai mon garçon
qui a eu son justement son BTA agricole
j'ai un autre qui a qui aide familiale
qui a fait un BTA aussi à
Saint-Benoît ma fille pas trop ma fille
elle elle va à l'école et en premierère
elle va à l'école ou mon mari lui il
travaille dans les chantiers mais ça
arrive que par la période du lait chi la
canne à sucre il met la la patte il me
donne un coup de main pour au moins pour
m'encourager mais vous ça pose pas de
problème vous arrivez à faire face à
toutes ces difficultés oui je fais c'est
un métier que j'aime donc je me donc
j'arrive mais vous n'avez pas fait ça au
départ comment ça vous est arrivé
l'envie de changer complètement de
métier on dira et et de préférer ce
métier de la terre disons
aussi j'ai j'aime bien changer j'aime
bien être responsable de mes actes là je
suis responsable je suis export agricole
je suis quand même responsable j'ai
encore plein plein de projets dans la
tête je fais partie du conseil municipal
de
sainrose je je suis aussi dans l'église
je m'occupe de de de l'église un peu
j'occupe de ma famille qui est
primordiale d'ailleurs et depuis combien
d'années vous êtes à la mairie j'ai fait
un mandat de 5 ans et peut-être un deuxè
bientôt est-ce que c'est important pour
vous d'être à cette place oui c'est très
important parce que je moi-même je peux
voir les difficultés qu'on rencontre
déjà d'agricultureord et déjà un et la
deuxième chose je fais partie du CCAS
aussi de sain- rose et là aussi je comme
je suis dans l'église je je je vois les
difficultés des gens qui qui qui ont pas
de travail qui ont des malheurs et je
peux intervenir au niveau de la mairie
pour ru d'accord c'est plus social alors
plus social je suis assez sociale quand
même je j'aime bien m'occuper des gens
qui ont besoin de l'aide pour remonter
la pente j'aime bien les j'aime
bien la femme peut faire autant autant
que l'homme bien sûr bien sûr il y a y a
il y a quand même les poids he disons un
poids de je dis ça mais je sais qu'il a
peut-être il y a des régimes de banane
que moi je pourrais porter et que
pourrait pas le porter je regrette oui
il y a des hommes et des hommes on nous
a fait passer pour des enfants pour des
des des enfants qui n'ont pas de force
qui n'ont pas assez de de intelligence
or que maintenant on voit des femmes
ministres quand même on voit des femmes
m on voit des
femmes conductrice de
autobus
agricultrice moi je dis la femme il faut
qu'elle a beaucoup plus d'ambition
qu'elle essaie d'avancer le travail le
travail d'un homme elle peut le faire
comme l'agriculture une femme si
vraiment elle le veut elle peut le faire
c'est pas difficile prendre un tomin
mettre un peu deserbon dans dans des
cannes le matin à 7h du matin c'est la
pé de toutes les femmes sauf si bien sûr
c'est une femme de salon elle pourra
sûrement pas d'accord mais vous ça ne
vous empêche pas d'être féminine ah je
suis très féminine oui ça m'empêche pas
mais si on m'admire je veux on m'admire
pour mes qualités ce qu' a dans ma tête
ma force mon caractère tout ça fait moi
mais la poupée je refuse
d'accord
endar